ما هو الوضع بشكل ادق في بخموت الاكيد انه
اذا نظرنا الى الخارطه الميدانيه الان
التقدم عسكريا واضح لصالح الجانب الروسي
نستطيع ان نرى انه خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
بعد قليل سنرى ربما خارطه تظهر كيفيه
تقدم الامور تحديدا في مدينه
بخمود الامر له علاقه بعمليه التطويق هذه
استراتيجيه سبق واستخدمها الجيش الروسي
مدعوما بفاجنر بعده مدن عديده انتظر خارطه
مفصله
لمدينه بخموته تحديدا تظهر ربما التقاطعات
ولماذا نتحدث عن تقدم واضح لهذه المدينه
بايه حل هناك كان تقدم مفصل نحن تحدثنا عن
ميدانيات حدثت وتحديدا سيطر على عدد من
القرى لكن شمال مدينه بخموت هناك هذه
القريه وهي او البلده كراسنا هورا مر
الامر مرور الكرام لكن عمليا الاعلان عن
السيطره عليها كان مهما جدا ميدانيا لماذا
لانه بالقرب من هذه المدينه هناك تقاطع
لطريقين الطريق ام سفر ثلاثه
وطريقه اخر ستاتي
0513 هذا يجري شمال
مدينه بخموت مع السيطره مع هذا الامر يعني
انه انضم الى جعبه القوات الروسيه طريق
اخر اساسي وبهذا تكون السيطره على ثلاث
طرق من اصل اربعه تصل الى مدينه بخموطه
الطريق الوحيده التي لا تزال حاليا بيد
القوات الاوكرانيه هي تلك التي تاتي من
الجنوب غرب تحديدا من ايفاني
هذا ما يجعل الامر صعبا جدا لجهه تزويد
القوات التي لا تزال داخل المدينه المتغير
الاخر هو عدم قدره مثلا خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه في شهر ديسمبر الماضيه الاسبوع
الماضي الصحفيون كانوا حتى لا يزالون
يستطيعون عبر بلده تدعى
الالتفاف قليلا والدخول الى المدينه
حتى اصبح صعبا للعياه هذا يعني انه عمليا
رغم ما يحكى عن تقدم اوكراني طفيف جنوب
غرب المدينه هذا يعني ان الامر ليس كافيا
على الاطلاق واذا نظرنا لجهه عسكريه بحته
نستطيع ان نتحدث عن تطويق لمدينه بخموت
بانتظار اعلان اخر
سوف يعلن وسوف ياتي في توقيته طب بالتالي
كيف يعني نفهم هذا التصريح لرئيس فاجنر
بانه يعني لن نحتفل حرفيا قال لنحتفل في
وقت قريب بسقوط مخبوط هذا كان التصريح
لافت للغايه وهذا لا ياتي من فراغ رغم هذا
التقدم العسكري الواضح للقوات الروسيه هو
قال تحديدا لن يتم الاستيلاء على مخمود
غدا لان هناك مقاومه قويه وقصفا مستمرا
مطحنه اللحم تعمل للمناسبه مطحنه اللحم او
مفرمه هو التعبير الذي استخدمه لبخموت منذ
بدايه الهجوم عليها على اعتبار ان عدد
الخسائر من الجانب الاوكراني بالنسبه له
قويه حسب التقديرات سقط في مدينه محمود من
الجانب روسي بين 15 الفا وثلاثين الفا ومن
الجانب الاوكراني الذي يتحفظ كثيرا على
خسائره في المدينه الامر سيكون مقاربا ان
لم يكن اكثر من هنا تعبير مطحنه اللحم
الان لماذا لم يتم الان الاعلان هناك عده
تفسيرات تستطيع ان تساعدنا على فهم هذا
التاخير اولا لان الجانب الروسي الذي
اعتاد على تطويق المدن يعلم جيدا هذا ما
حدث في ماريبو الحدث في سوليدار انه
لدرء خسائره هو يستطيع دائما ان يترك
منفذا من الغرب هذه هي مدينه طبخموت هذه
الطرقات التي اصبحت كلها تحت السيطره
الروسيه الطريق الوحيده قليلا هي التي
تاتي من هنا والتي حتى اللحظه لا تزال من
الجانب الاوكراني اذا الجانب الروسي يعلم
انه عندما يترك مجالا للخروج للقوات
الاوكرانيه الموجوده المتحصنه حتى في
خنادق فهو قد يخاد اولا قد يقلل من خسائره
ثانيا هناك نقطه بالغه الاهميه السيطره
على مخمود لا يمكن النظر الى الحرب في
اوكرانيا بصفه هذه النقطه التي للمناسبه
متنازع حتى على مدى استراتيجيات بخموت
لماذا حتى لو تمت السيطره على مخمود هنا
في تشارلي سيار هناك مرتفعات القوات
الاوكرانيه تستطيع دائما ان
تسلط المدفعيه وغيرها على مخموت اكثر من
هذا هناك جبهه شمالا وعندها
اوكرانيه عندها تستطيع الجانب الاوكراني
ايضا ان يضرب بضع خاصرات رخوه واهم من هذا
كله اذا نظرنا الى الصوره الكبرى الجانب
الروسي يعول على نقطه تفوق اساسيه ومهمه
لديه عدد جنود اكبر هو مدعوم بيفاجنر
ولديه ذخيره اكبر وبالتالي كلما طالت
معركه استنزاف هناك عمل على جبهات اخرى لا
نتحدث عنها كثيرا نحن الان نقول مخمود
مخمود مخمود لكن علينا ان ننظر ما يجري في
جنوبا وما يجري في خرسون
اشغال الجانب الاوكراني بشكل هائل هنا هذا
يعني انه عندما نكون هنا في دنياتك امورنا
هذا يعني ان هناك اي تقدم وحشد عسكري في
خير
يستطيع ان يضعف الجانب الاوكراني وهذا
بالمناسبه تكتيك حتى استخدم لدى
الاوكرانيين سابقا للقول نشغلهم في بخموت
تسقط الخسائر كثيرا بالنسبه الى فاجنر مهم
جدا السيطره على مخموت ولكن في حقيقه
الامر نكون ندعم الجبهات شمال بخموت
ونحاول ان ندرى الهجوم الذي سياتي سواء من
خرسون او اذا كلها عمليه
استراتيجيات لكن في الوقت الحالي الاكيد
انه اذا نظرنا الى مخموت لا شك ان التفوق
العسكري بلا شك هو لصالح الجانب الروسي
شكرا شكرا لك